la cure de saint pierre
au xviiie siècle les lazaristes
bâtissent des églises dans les
différents quartiers de la colonie il
construit également neuf cure pour loger
les prêtres dotée d'un étage celle de
saint-denis et de saint-pierre sont les
plus grandes
à thenon aux églises ses deux cures sont
en basalte enduits à la chaux
difficile à travailler cette pierre est
alors réservé aux édifices les plus
importants de la colonie
identique au premier étage au
rez-de-chaussée la distribution
intérieure une salle centrale entourée
de quatre pièces attenantes est
caractéristique de l'architecturé
française de l'époque
l'édifice dispose à l'origine de deux
warrants elles sont fermées à la suite
du cyclone de 1773 huit ans à peine
après la construction de la cure
implanté face à la mer au sommet d'une
colline la cure de saint-pierre domine
la ville et l'église
de plan rectangulaire elle surmontée
d'une haute toiture à quatre pans à
l'origine couverte de bach dont
la vaste salle à manger qui se situe à
l'arrière du bâtiment est en pierre de
taille
achevé en 1765 la cure de saint pierre
est l'une des plus vieilles maisons de
la ville c'est à ce titre qu'elle a été
classée monument historique en 1998
la cure de saint denis qui a servi de
modèle aux lazaristes pour édifier celle
de saint pierre a été construite une
dizaine d'années plus tôt situé dans le
centre historique du chef lieu elle est
l'un des plus anciens bâtiments de lille